what up there friends about a week ago I
uploaded a video on how you can learn
the three beat weave in only 30 minutes
hopefully there's a bunch more of you
out there that are doing The Weave now
and I want to show you how to transition
in and out of
it Drex here from Drex Factor Poise
sharing with you the love of pois
spinning and flow Arts to benefit your
body and brain and today I am showing
you how to transition in and out of one
of the most recognizable po moves of all
time but before we dive in I just want
to give a quick shout out to the Friends
of the channel big thanks to dark bunk
fire Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro teror light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping to make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non-b buus friend of the
channel Becca Becken thank you so much
for supporting my channel my work and my
mission so I think that three beat
weaves get a little bit of a bum wrap
when it comes to pois spinning in
general and also transitions because
they're so associated with beginner poy
I think people kind of forget about them
and leave them by the wayside and beyond
that because our hands are Tangled Up
and twisted up for most of the duration
of the move I think a lot of people also
just assumed that there's not really a
lot of transition possibilities there
and you know what they're wrong so I'm
going to give you what currently on
paper is eight different possibilities
for transitions using three beat weaves
although some of them may have some
additional possibilities nestled inside
of them and I'm going to work my way up
from beginner to intermediate and then
Advanced transitions so buckle up okay
so it's got to be said that when it
comes to Transitions with weaves one of
those things that we really have to
contend with is the fact that quite a
lot of transitions with 3 beat weaves
are are things that kind of have their
own names and become thought of as
tricks in their own right so we're
starting this one off with just the
waist strap that is turning from a
forwards to reverse weave and then back
again uh you can do this either going
just back and forth across the front of
your body or you can take it in a full
360° if you so choose that's totally up
to you this is one of those absolute
Staples and something that quite frankly
was a big piece of inspiration to me
when I first started spinning this was
that thing that when I saw it performed
I was just like okay I'm I'm all in I
want to figure out how to do this one
and of course from that waist strap it
is barely a step forward to then take it
up and around and add what feels like a
windmill on top of it to get the fourbe
fountain out of it this is the first
thing that I ever learned that I
actually thought of as being a POI
transition taking my forwards to reverse
weaves back and forth in this waist
trrap and then figuring out a way to
take them up into a windmill awesome so
with the basics out of the way let's
start getting into some stuff that I
think is more intermediate level for
these POI Transitions and we're going to
start that off with
1.5s that is this version of what feels
a little bit like a 3B weave but you're
expanding out and adding pendulums to
either side of it the idea here is
basically the same thing as the 3 beat
weave except that whichever hand is
going on top as you switch sides
suddenly rises above and gives you a
pendulum instead of a static spin to go
around and perform your weaves with you
just got to open up and essentially turn
what was a 3B weave into what I now
realize is a cap and of course the real
fun of this is being able to open up and
then close again and open up and then
close again going back and forth between
them really what makes this work is
something that's going to be a big help
with transitions down the road and
that's realizing that on either side of
the 3B weave there's a point where your
arms come untwisted for a second and
that's a moment where you can do
something different in the case of doing
the 1.5 beat weave that's the moment
where you can pull one hand out and have
it jump up above and do a pendulum
instead of one of those beats so be on
the lookout for that as we go further
into this list awesome so next up we're
going to utilize our first transition
that takes advantage of the fact that
three beat weaves involve twisting and
untwisting our hands so rather than
looking for that moment of Separation
we're instead looking towards that
moment where our arms cross why because
that actually is the perfect way to get
into a PO Crosser where that's right we
mean to keep our hands crossed really
what makes this work is we're looking
for that moment where we go from our
hands uncrossed to our hands crossed
again and from there we can just convert
that into a set of shoulder reels we're
just doing it with our arms crossed
instead of our arms uncrossed so rather
than this we're going to this it just so
happens that the 3B weave offers a great
way to get into that position no mus no
fuss next up another kind of obvious one
but one that I'm going to add
nonetheless is that when you get your 5
beat weaves down guess what this does
technically count as a transition when
you go back and forth between the three
beat weave and the five beat weave what
you're doing is just adding an extra
degree of twist but hey a transition
nonetheless it still counts and of
course we can also play around with the
position where our hands open to go into
one of my favorite big poy moves namely
we can take this split Time same
direction feel and as we open up our
hands we can take it around into Giants
where we're basically doing shoulder
reels with our shoulders going full
length all the way around before we
collapse back down into that three beat
weave again we go
big and then we can take it back small
again all right so I would consider all
of that a smash mattering of
intermediate petrix now it's time to
dive into some of the advanced and some
of the weird stuff all right so for this
next bunch of transitions I'm basically
adding a whole bunch of stuff all into
one category and I'm referring to that
category as hybrids namely one of the
things we can do here is go into both
our Vulcan Tech gospel hybrids as well
as some of our weirder and more exotic
hybrids like trra versus pendulum let's
take a look at both all right so the
operating principle here is recognizing
that when we're performing this 3B weave
we're essentially keeping our hands
together out to the side and that means
that we can think of this as being a
position of transition for timing and
Direction both of our hands out to the
side that means we can either go around
in Split time opposites or if we prefer
in together same like so so this leaves
us a bunch of possibilities whether we
want to just keep the PO consistently in
the original timing and direction of
split Time same direction and and
separate out into something like four
pedal anti- spin versus two pedal in
spin or we could do something like
taking the hands together in a buzz saw
flower going around in two different
versions of four pedal antipin like so
or we can get a little weird so we also
have the possibility here of switching
into some hybrids that have some more
exotic qualities to them so for instance
we could go around in pendulum versus
Tri ketra like so and and then switch
back in and there's also a whole host of
variations on that because we can do the
same hybrid in Split opposites of
course what I really like about that
hybrid though is that it's essentially a
cap and there's a lot of ways that you
can split a cap he he aren't I clever
one of which being that you can take the
point isolation out of the top of this
hybrid and instead add in a point
isolation like so giving us something
that I like to think of as the accordion
hybrid and of course just like there's a
version of that where the hands go
around together same there is also a
version of it where the hands go around
in together opposite like so and either
way when the hands come back together
over on the right you can switch back
into that weave nicely done all right so
for our final transition here it's going
to get super weird I'm going to take my
weaves into wheel plane relative to the
audience we never ever ever show people
po from this perspective and I think
that's kind of a shame because there's a
fun plane changing combo that we can do
from here namely when I have one hand
crossed over the other I can open up
close again and switch back into the 3B
weave what is this sorcery let me show
you I'm looking for this moment where I
have my right hand wrapped over my left
and I'm going to treat that moment as a
stall bring my left hand out and then
use a set of split Time same direction
stalls to bring my right up my left down
I bring my right back over and boom I
bring my left on top of my right hand
same thing again boom right stalls we do
the other stalls over and we're back
into the weave I stall bring it out
switch around and here we go and again
from under I stall stall bring it over
and we're back to the weave pretty wild
huh all right so let me show you a bunch
of these beles in action so you can see
how they all fit together
[Music]
good deal I hope that was helpful and it
gave you'all all some inspiration out
there but if you are looking for more
guidance on how to move around with your
weaves you're un luck cuz I'm starting
up a new round of live stream POI dance
classes starting May 21st I'm teaching a
4-we course that is going to guide you
through not only amazing transitions
that you can do with your weaves but
also how to dance and present them
what's more I will have a full POI
choreographed combo for you to learn
over the course of those four weeks so
you can impress your friends and family
registration is open now over at
crowdcast doio drexfactor poy see you in
class did you get anything out of this
video please make sure to like share
comment and subscribe to help other
people find it and of course to help my
channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without my amazing supporters on patreon
in particular I'd love to give a shout
out to my flow patrons who are listed on
screen right now thank you so much for
supporting my channel my work and my
mission and if you out there watching
like the work I produce and you'd like
to see more of it there's an easy way to
do that head on over to patreon at
patreon.com drexfactor poy and sign up
to support my work you can get access to
a whole host of awesome rewards but even
better than that you'll be helping me
out in my mission to bring po spinning
and flow Arts to the whole wide world go
check that out please and thank you and
if you just can't get enough of those
weaves and challenging yourself well I
uploaded a video on five different skill
levels of the 3B weave that I'll go
ahead and link to down in the
description as well as up on screen if
you're watching on YouTube thanks so
much for watching make sure to get out
and flow yourself today and I'll see you
with a new video real soon take care now
peace